vous faites partie des nombreuses
équipes de scientifiques rassemblés pour
lancer la mission jeanne rose qui
consiste à installer une base habitable
l'espace d'une avant midi les
scientifiques sont les élèves de
secondaire 4 du programme galilée de
l'école louis riel et polytechnique et
l'équipe d'animation scientifique de
polytechnique qui dirige laventure un
éveil à la science et à l'ingénierie au
cours de votre mission vous devrez
construire quatre bâtiments en vous
fiant au plan produit par nos ingénieurs
aujourd'hui vous allez avoir appliqué un
peu du génie civil vous allez avoir
l'informatique c'est un jeu de rôle les
élèves se mettre dans la peau de
quelqu'un qui veut que l'elysée
nouvelle planète qu'on a découvert puis
la communication en fait entre les
membres de l'équipe se fait via courriel
et donc ils doivent lire des courriels
répondre à des questions de
mathématiques qui vont leur donner des
matériaux supplémentaires pour avoir une
colonie plus volumineuse
lisez bien c'est important de le lire
chaque question une bonne réponse
rapproche leur équipe de la victoire
mais plusieurs dangers les guettent et
c'est là le principal objectif du jeu
déceler les pièges tendus par les
pirates informatiques et les fraudeurs
qui leur font perdre des matériaux de
construction
un obus et c'était la victoire donc
ouais c'était c'était tentant d'avoir
plus de une deux sens pas toujours
facile avec lui concerne les petits
cubains ont quitté pour le fun au final
on perd mais les matériaux les amazones
donc plus d'informations des bus avec
edf pour faire de la guitare et des
informations
[Musique]
s'il tarde trop beau pour être vrai on
veut leur donner des cadeaux des choses
gratuites ou si on leur demande d
information personnelle des informations
de leur compte de banque ou et donc on
essaie de repérer ce le prof de maths
qui avait cédé sa période est satisfait
c'est carrément les élèves qui sont des
semaines mais font preuve de leur
intelligence à la base donc c'est très
très très très intéressant l'équipe
polytechnique offre mission au génial
cette toutes les écoles secondaires de
la région métropolitaine et attendent
maintenant les invitations tient
vraiment à coopérer en équipe sur le
plan scientifique et mathématique
aujourd'hui on a découvert à prendre en
même temps s'amuse ici seule belle miley
radio canada montréal
[Musique]